American accents are familiar to us and
English accents sounds smart to us what
do you think they'll strike that is the
thing if there was a fire in the
building right now right and there was a
British accent that went there is a fire
in the building please leave the
building you'd all get up and run and
think that but with my voice if I just
win there's a fire everyone everyone
here in a lot of your in a lot of danger
you'd be like ah he'll be ok one of
those broad shouldered men I am
well you're a real man yes Australian
that's the official I once I once went
in for an audition and and the lady was
like these vitamins and stuff on the
table I don't know what has to do with
it sure and she went she went so where
are you from where are you from and I
mean I'm estranged cuz that's good don't
like the British ones they're too girly
[Applause]
nothing because you can say what Mel
Gibson whatever he said doesn't matter
he's a real man
in Texas you can open carry a gun you
can have a sniper rifle which is not a
protection gun in any way no one's ever
sat in their front yard looking through
a thing looking at something for miles
around thought if this guy keeps coming
towards my family you can open carry a
machine gun in target you can't open
carry a chainsaw that would be
ridiculous you can't walk into target
with your chainsaw and go this is more
protection chainsaw chainsaw to protect
me and my family the only way to stop a
bad guy with a chainsaw is a good guy
with a chainsaw
I wanted to do like a ride-along with
some police in Britain cuz it's funny
because they don't have guns they're
really just guys in cars with sticks
just running around the suburbs like
stop it I've got a stick I got a bit of
pepper sprays and I kick off because I
pepper and stick yeah some of the elite
cops in Britain have like tasers but
they're like war they brought in the
tasers Britain has less weapons than a
standard person walking the streets in
America all right well the night before
has met be on the show I was
masturbating and when I died I guess
yeah where are Jack you lated blood came
out and I thought hmm
that's not good right and then I wait a
minute wait just hold on a second you
can't just launch into this is blood
shot out this is horrifying what I was
Jackson Pollock painting something it
was just blood blood just shot out of
the end of my penis
I remember being concerned but I had to
get up early in the morning to do my
show so I was like I better sleep
stressful sleep right but then when you
wake up in the morning you think just
you know I have to check if this is
going to happen again
so I had another one you know another
wank is that that's a hard one to get
aroused for knowing that you might have
blood coming at the end of your dick
right so I did it again blood again
Conan twice right and then over the
course of the day before I was meant to
be a show one of my testicles swelled up
into the size of a grapefruit and I
thought best that I don't do Conan show
because I couldn't walk there's like
everybody's like those those space
operas that blow-up balloon that you
hold the two ears when you're a kid yeah
that's how I look but I only had one ear
to hold on to and I said I met the lady
who Castle a Martin Scorsese's film and
my manager isn't high enough up in the
company he goes I can't talk to her
she's too big for me but there's someone
in the office who can write and the big
person in the office rang her up and
said I hear you just met Jim Jeffries
and she's like what a delightful young
man I've never met such a charming young
man he goes she goes I want to screen
test him I think he's a star he's got it
all
right they bring me back like a she
loves you and I'm like brilliant whole
life made right and then then five
minutes later I get a phone call I go
she just watched some of you stand up
she's not interested say you won't be
seeing me in a Martin Scorsese film
anytime soon but I can't imagine this
ever gonna be an Australian character in
Goodfellas to just walk in like better
been better book I could hey guys what's
up
who are we killing I once did another
show that was similar to this show and I
say would blow piss tonight anyway so it
doesn't exist anymore so who cares and
the other guest was Justin Bieber and I
was just sitting backstage and was me
and the Biebs and the Biebs must have
been about 16 super nice kid he's mum's
the same age as me because she had him
at like 16 or something like that and
I'm sitting there I got 11 year old
niece in Australia so I go look I never
do this to anyone but can I just ring up
my niece and if you could just speak to
her for just a second I'd be the
greatest uncle ever
and he said sure anything for a belieber
he said it right I love that so I got up
in front of him put the phone on
speakerphone I rang my niece a minister
I was like midday there I said how are
you semi it's your favorite uncle Jim
now I know what a big Justin Bieber fan
you are and she goes I hate him now I
like one direction
[Laughter]
the whole thing and I was like well he
really wants to talk to you he was super
cool about it I think it happened to him
before good things you have the
cranberry you have something it is
stuffing the stuffing does my head II
III don't even breathe stuffing up
because everyone's got like a
grandmother or a mother and they're like
dude my mother makes this stuffing and
it is literally my favorite thing in the
world and she only makes it one day a
year and I'm like is your mother an
[ __ ] why is it every Tuesday stuffing
day I fed him chicken I cooked up some
chick you cook chicken that's a that's a
good dad yeah daddy likes chicken so I
made him some chicken and then I fed him
the chicken and I ate some of the
chicken as well and then like we went to
bed he went to bed at like 9:00 I went
to bed at like 11:00 or something and
about 11 o'clock he wakes up just
screaming dad died and he's holding he's
happening because I gave him food
poisoning you see and and he's just and
he's like he's crying he's like I've
never felt so much pain died and so he
goes up to the toilet I just watch him
he's [ __ ] himself and it's weird
it's weird when you're four because you
think well this is me now he just
thought he's gonna spend the rest of his
life on a toilet
oh he just thought he was dying Wow I
said you're gonna be fine mate you're
gonna be fine I gave him in a mo diem
and they were tums to settle his stomach
and a baby tylenol now you're overdoing
it with the bed just take it easy
I'll let him come and sleep in me
betting I gave my cattle I said you're
gonna be alright mate anyway an hour
about two hours later I wake up and I
start [ __ ] myself but today my
system and I'm sitting on the toilet and
I'm just [ __ ] myself I'm like crying
and then he he walks in holding his
teddy and he's hairs or flapping he's in
his pajamas and he looks at me he goes
we had a tough night didn't we do
America does everything that you name
people who don't use the metric system
would you don't get stupid because like
like you should work in Celsius freezing
point is zero the boiling point is 100
it makes same it does make your your
number is it freezes at twenty seven
point six I don't know right but it's
ridiculous wherever you do it they're
putting putting the month first yeah the
month the day and then the year
shouldn't do that oh should be the day
first then it should be the smallest
amount the medium amount and then the
largest amount right because the day is
the most important thing right when
someone asks you the date you don't go
July should be the most important bit
first so today's the twelve right I
don't even bother dude I still stick to
me guns I thought I was coming here in
December
[Applause]
I'm sure I've ruined many contracts in
my career is there a god ah no we're
both atheist I looked like an atheist
you look like the lead singer of a
Christian band I'm not an atheist I'm
kind of open to lots of things in a
theist I get I like them I'll enjoy that
as one of the options I'm a big I think
the the problem is a lot of Christians
were the atheist that we're just going
to be animals and we're going to be bad
people because we don't have any
restrictions but you know it's life is
just try not to be a that's that's all
life is the first day I meet George
Lazenby I'm sitting next to him and I
thought I've got to ask this question
and I said George you have a the bongo
and George Wayne I'd be easier to tell
you which ones I haven't tell you which
ones I haven't and then and then you
guys they all come to the conventions so
George hasn't had sex with these women
in their prime
these are six of them in a motel six
with all their head shots around the
room George has got to be the only like
not even Timothy Dalton shows up to the
convention do you think he's the only
bond that goes like yeah and like
Connery isn't going to conventions he's
somewhere in a two-year old
doing this one this is why we're not
Fred
science tells us the more talented you
are the more likely you are to get away
with a crime it's called the fame to
blame ratio as you can see here
as you can see here labeled in the no
jail area all the celebrities that we
loved and the celebrities down here the
celebrities that we didn't love enough
our favorite sandwich enthusiast Jared
just as creepy not very talented my
son's a loser is what happened no he
really is his best friend Z's mom hey if
you meet any guys like my mom she's like
my best friend that's it that's a
freaking loser okay but he still lives
at home hasn't moved out loser if you've
got kids no I don't have any cards it's
an exciting way to ruin a relationship
I am I went when the girl stops
breastfeeding yeah but it's go like
rock-hard kind of like a tempurpedic
mattress it's you could put a glass one
and punch the other one in the Lonmin
yeah